welcome to this video for the final
round of the candidates tournament
and um yeah okay we already have a
winner in this event so
it's um
not about any
suspension anymore about first place
but there are still some games to be
played in this final round and this
video is about the gamer medjarov
krumnick
both players are on
fifty percent if i'm not mistaken
kromnic
had beaten topalov in the penultimate
round
and certainly got in some some kind of
revenge and um
yeah still it's not a good event for him
and um
he probably is glad that
it's over
but okay let's look at this game
all right so we got the nimzo and
mamadiarov um
had played
the nimzo two times with white already
with white
um
with the white already
had a bit of a strange sentence but it's
already late here
when i'm recording so um sorry for that
yeah he had played the white side of the
nimzo two times and had played f3 both
times beating aronian in a very
important game for the overall
development of this tournament
and he had played f3 to
draw against kayak in a very sharp game
um this time however is going for queen
c2 which is
of course um somewhat more solid line
l3 is arguably one of the sharpest
continuations
queensy team queen c2 obviously
has the idea to get this type of
position where
white has not
been settled with them with double pawns
it's um
only the queen that needed to move like
two times
plus a3 so white has lost quite
some time to achieve this goal
and
it's exactly this
development lag
that
gives black chances
chronic plays d5 and this is his
trademark move he has
made this his main weapon against the
the nimzo for a number of years now
and
it already had been played in this
tournament this position
um in round one he got this against
andreikin
and exactly this happened
in that drake in cromley game
however in this position
after queen d7
and draken played the move queen c2
and
we got a very long theoretical um
discussion in this game which at the end
um ended in a draw white
took later played queen to e4
and went to the kings side
yara forever after some thought
exchanged on this heaven a bit a bit
weird maybe had
somehow
i don't know forgotten his preparation
or confused something
um hard to tell but what we get now
is um
yeah absolutely uh absolutely nothing
for white
the capture knight bd7 black is uh
almost fully developed now and is ready
to um
put
a rook on the c farm and play c5 like
that or rook c8 and c5 this is the only
thing that black still needs to solve
he has a potentially problematic
backward c pawn and if he manages to
exchange that for the d4 pawn it's a
complete equality
also note that the bishop on a6 is
nicely placed so that
the development is not so
so easy for white
let's say if white goes like g3 bishop
g2 there's always e2 hanging
white is going for
this capture
which looks um yeah and looks very tame
to give up the bishop like that but i
think he wanted to get e5 for the knight
this was the idea to play with e3 and in
this position in fact it is interesting
that kromnic played bishop to b7 which
is probably a very precise move
if you take
after rook takes
rook c8
rook
c1 it's not 100 clear that black can
equalize
i mean he's obviously very close to
being equal
but um it's not clear if it is a
complete equality if you
want to
check some lines let's say black goes c5
white will capture
and
yeah how do you actually
get it back now
one idea could be knight to d7 but here
they go here there is c6
and you cannot
go here
the knight does not have any
any decent square
if you look at this
white will probably get some play
against the c pawn
there's always this potential idea
we will probably start with something
like that that's also not not entirely
equal or
this type of structure
the knight coming here is also slightly
more comfortable
he went to b7 and
this has one uh
one
important point
if you look at this now rook c1
rook c8
knight e5
white in order to get developed would
need to move the bishop and
this
is just just somewhat quicker in
comparison
with the other with the other position
now
something like 92 or this g2 hanging
this should be seven um it's just a bit
more precise it does not help white
to um
to connect the rooks quickly so bishop
b7 is better rook c1
rook c8
and knight e5 played yeah this is
directed against the knight d7 but black
can
prepare that rook d8
f3 yeah this is the problem this bishop
on a move like that like it's just going
to take it
so f3
yeah and now we get
this c5 break in
takes and 97 again
very precise black is not even getting a
weak pawn now
takes takes
and now e4 is played yeah white can also
try to start with b4 but
this pawn is um i mean white will not
keep the pawn of course
it's um it's even uh why needs to be a
bit precise to not be worse as he's
really behind in development but after
e4
king of eight
now before this was played
and after after these moves
yeah they need to put put some more
moves on the board
because they can only agree after 30
moves
um
and here they they actually did agree to
a draw yeah this is of course a bit of a
non-game
but um it still contains um
a slight uh slide point this bishop b7
move
it's uh it's not rocket science i
understand but uh
even if you think that okay white is
playing a very very uh
unambitious kind of setup yeah that's
maybe true but uh still if you take here
you might get into position that uh that
lets
that just bit suffering
and bishop b7 is just more precise after
that it's completely
completely equal maybe uh mamjarov was
um just trying to set this
this little problem and um said that
okay
i'm trying to test him in this way if he
goes with the capture i might have a
little something and if he plays
precisely it's going to be a drawing
well wrapping up this event on 50
percent is
is not what
both players had imagined but
yeah well you're not going to
it does not make a lot of sense to risk
it all here and even get back to a minus
score
so a draw
to uh finish this tournament
muhammad yarov
finish on 50 percent
which for kramnik is certainly a
disappointment he made
many many
yeah you can always almost call it
blunders really which um
totally untypical of his place so he
will be certainly
analyzing um and trying to figure out
what uh what was going on there
he certainly is able to do uh to do much
better
yeah mommy jaroff also uh it it became
apparent in in lots of games that he had
put in really a good amount of work he
had
some games where you basically you felt
that he was very uh well prepared
but
the
maybe the crucial moment was the the
first
um in the first leg of the tournament in
round seven
when those two players when with the
aravind kramnik met member yarov had a
winning position with black against
kromnik this would have
given mahmoud yaro from a plus one score
after he had lost two games early he
would have
completed a great comeback and this was
maybe the
the make or break point of this
tournament for kramnik it certainly was
the loss against topalov which uh
which was a bit
yeah not a bit quite
quite shocking for him i guess because
it also was such a drastic loss without
and really getting on the board
okay i still hope you enjoyed the
brief coverage of
this game it might help you if you play
this line of the nimso but um
other than that i understand there have
been more interesting
games for sure
okay thanks for watching